so i got a question for you if there was
a scoreboard
of your life of where you're currently
at versus your capacity
how would the scoreboard look for you
i'm patrick with davey your host of
valuetainment weekly and i'll tell you
one of the things that used to bother me
the most when i got out of the military
was
every time i looked at the scoreboard of
life of what i could do i kept feeling
like i'm way behind and i'm way behind
and i'm way behind and i'm way behind
i'm always falling behind
and it doesn't make you feel good i
don't know if you've been there before
and it would give me this feeling of
panic
anxiety and fear and how do we feel
when we have those three feelings in our
lives think about it so i asked the
question
well what is panic stemmed from
what causes us to panic what causes
us to have fears what causes us to be
having anxiety attacks initially a lot
of times we think
it's somebody else's fault because of
this person or that person or this
person or that person or
other people right i realize it has
nothing to do with them
all of those things have to do with me
and then i said so now next step when
you study this subject
what creates panic what creates fears
what creates anxiety attacks you start
realizing
what causes that because in reality what
we would all
like to have is a life with little to no
anxiety right uh a little to no
panic and little to no fears it's never
going to be
none completely but as little as
possible so how do we do that
three things three things it takes for
that to take place
one one it's having a
high level of urgency in life let me
explain
you see when you look at the score of
life and you may say i'm behind because
they got a lead on me my potential does
and i'm not there yet
well how urgent are you about catching
up
most people don't live life being too
urgent most people are too hurry
they walk fast everything is just quick
and they feel like they're doing things
but it's kind of like me just
turning in the same place you're not
really getting anything done you're
still standing in the same place
urgency is going next what do i do next
what do i do next what do i do next
performers have higher expectation of
being urgent than the rest of the people
do
second thing i'll tell you is having
been there before
what does that mean if i am facing a
problem that i've been there before
i know handle it a lot better than
before because it isn't my first time
there so
you need to put yourself in situations
where you don't know how to handle it
you learn you come back and better and
you go you learn come back and better
and better and eventually
it's just like shooting a free throw
like some of these professionals because
you've been there before
and the last one that'll take a lot of
the stress and the anxiety away
is preparation preparation
preparation so few people prepare
and you are not going to make it to the
top level of performance
and competing if you don't prepare i
learned it the hard way i'm telling you
from pure experience
just because you're talented or you
speak well or you do well all that stuff
if you are not urgent about life if
you're not constantly putting yourself
in a situation that you've been there
before and you know what to do next
and if you're not preparing life's gonna
constantly create
panic stress fear
anxiety and you'll always look at the
scoreboard of life saying
why am i still losing versus my
potential
my challenge to do to you is get it
together
put a plan of action and start beating
your potential
start beating your potential do better
than what you thought you could do
yourself
and that's what takes you in the unknown
part of life
and the unknown part of life is
unpredictable and it's
juicy you experience things you've never
experienced before
that's the juice of life that you want
to get into anyways i got to go out and
hit some balls and let's see how i'll do
if i
miss some of them with these underhand
balls they're thrown please do not laugh
at me
meanwhile please be sure to subscribe on
this channel
and comment on the bottom
oh no
notice this is why i do financial
services
are you kidding me